what are your investment criteria yes so
here's the gift that I have and there
you have but a lot of VCS don't have
okay let me hear it is that we are
including is that we've done it so here
so I so first I met with all these
startups alright and I took warm intros
which I don't do anymore and I and I met
with folks that were just looking for
money which I don't do anymore and then
I bought and then I realized I could
boil all this stuff down to two and a
half investment criterion you just find
one and this is the one that feces that
haven't been founders don't get founder
has to be better than me founder has to
be better than me the way I figured it
if if I could have basically a low nine
figure exit in 2011 and SAS if the
founder is much better than me
then they have a shot at a unicorn or at
least a 1% chance right but it's so hard
to be a founder for five years seven
years and in SAS it's even harder
because it's very cross-functional I
need a VP of Sales VP of Marketing vp a
product vp a customer's ticket i can't
just sit in my office and be cool and so
unique it's so it's so hard so if you're
not better than me there's just no
chance right anyone that i meet i don't
care what the numbers look like the pre
traction and I don't care how cool the
product is if they're not better than me
I'm done hmm right and and most species
have no idea what that means but you
know someone that's better than you
don't you how long does it take you to
figure it out very quickly I mean I
think my preternatural ability is being
able to know somebody's resilience
somebody's ability yeah in a first five
minutes of meeting them yeah I can
really tell I mean three years of poker
years of beating with people and being a
journalist like your radar just becomes
I mean sometimes I'm wrong but not all
know I met Travis kalanick who wouldn't
remember me from anything
yeah right after his lot red sushi was
that his last coming to get it sold I
met him and had a bit of lunch there's a
big neon sign above his head that says
winner yeah and I met this guy to lunch
you know this is a long time ago this
must have been early 2005 does sound
about right so much yeah and he
explained the entire future video on the
Internet to me at lunch and I'm like
this is one of the smartest people I've
ever met on the entire planet Yeah right
and then now that I'm an investor now if
it was someone like that in SAS with ten
customers mm-hm I mean yeah okay so just
as a touch point here right just so much
better right right
so number one has to be better than me
and there's so many founders and they're
great and I love them and and we're I
together but I can't invest if they're
not better than me it's too all right
that's an intro second criteria which
ties to talk to us and some of the
others were talking about what I learned
is you know I got a product I dragged a
product up from nothing to eight figures
in recurring revenue add/edit at a
blended price point there was about
fifteen bucks per user per month what
I'm looking for our better unit
economics than I had because if your
deal size not just your really your
pricing but the total deal size is
higher than I had then for the same
amount of work you're gonna get there
faster right right so simple so if your
product seven bucks a month five bucks a
month three bucks a month generally
speaking I'm out right it's just on
Apple I give apples you know Android
might have might outsell Apple you know
five ten to one yes and they don't make
any money yes
per unit the eunich anomic SAR terrible
right so if the founder if the founders
better than me but the unit economics
are even worse his of his or her ability
to get to a hundred million in revenue
it's just it's too hard
they're sprints on that oatmeal I'm
writing throat meal throat meal so when
I look like a talk to us we could we can
try to put some other case studies talk
to sky invested you know last summer at
million in revenue now it's an eight
figures one of the amazing CEO better
than me amazing team--amazing everything
but one of the one of its secret sauces
is when I invested the product was I
don't know on average probably fifteen
or twenty dollars a month now it's a
hundred mmm so it just is and they've
worked incredibly hard than amazed job
but if they done the same amount of work
and still had a low-end cheap product it
just wouldn't have quantitatively it
wouldn't have gotten as far right so
it's got to have better you know
economics maybe better found her and
then that's really it but then there's a
third criteria which you you have to
worry about an angel investing but it's
even more important with institutional
money if you don't have a billion dollar
fund which is I will invest in companies
that are very boring today another call
center software another QA software
another search is a service company
another ediscovery company these are
four that I've done that will be I think
will be unicorns but if I could say if I
say on call center searches a service
I'm QA as a service and ediscovery as a
service you're just gonna yawn right
you're like oh that didn't work boring
boring what I need to know is the net
sky won't think it's boring hmm right
that that it will become a hot company
got it because the next guy like the
further you go downstream it has to
become hot or no one's gonna pay the
crazy valuations we need